[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président du
Sénat monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Président de l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur le Président du
Conseil économique social
environnemental mesdames messieurs les
ministres mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires mesdames Messieurs les
élus mesdames messieurs en vos grades et
qualités je suis très heureux d'être
parmi vous aujourd'hui parce que vous
venez de le rappeler par vos propos ce
dont nous allons parler c'est au fond de
la vie quotidienne des Français et de
leur avenir et pas d'autre chose et en
vérité on choisit le terme de territoire
faute de mieux les Français parlent
assez peu de territoire c'est un mot
dont nous nous parlons mais les Français
parlent de leurs campagn de leur
montagnes de leurs forêt de la mer de
leurs villes de leur villagees leurs
plaines de leur
banlieu de la diversité qui fait leur
quotidien
et c'est au fond le cœur du sujet qui
nous est ainsi
posé nous sommes dans un pays qui s'est
est construit par la
norme par la langue par l'État par
l'impôt il faut bien le dire aussi son
administration et dont les grands
vecteurs en quelque sorte d'omogénéité
ont été imposé d'en
haut or notre pays est fait de
géographie multiple nous restons
éminemment un pays de terroir et de
géographe et dans une mondialisation qui
tente à tout homogénéiser l'attachement
de nos concitoyens à leur quotidien à la
réalité de leur territoire est encore
plus grande chaque jour et le défi qui
est le nôtre il n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
mais il est chaque jour un peu plus fort
c'est de
conjuguer l'unité de la République qui
nous a faite cette mondialisation qui
parfois bouscule des grands équilibres
et dans laquelle nous avons à avancer et
la diversité de ces
territoires qui est constitutif de nos
identités et de notre identité profonde
et c'est tout le défi qui est le nôtre
parce que cette pluralité de situation
nos concitoyens la vivent dans leur
quotidien et ils n'ont pas le même
quotidien celon qu'ils habitent un
territoire très rural une banlieue
métropolitaine une ville moyenne de
province ou qu'il soit dans un
territoire ultramarin ou une zone de
montagne nous le savons bien et les
tentations des extrêmes que vous avez
réévoqué sont alimentés par le sentiment
chaque jour documenté il faut bien le
dire que notre approche est monolitique
unilatérale univoque et au principe
d'égalité sur lequel notre République
s'est construite nous devons bien
aujourd'hui
considérer en quelque sorte une forme
d'attention toute particulière à une
égalité des chances des territoires car
égalité qui crée de l'uniformité
n'assure plus l'égalité des chances sur
la totalité de notre territoire
aujourd'hui c'est cette sensibilité qui
nourrit les inquiétudes les incertitudes
que je sais nombreuses que cette
conférence nationale des territoires
et c'est mon souhait profond que notre
action collective dans les prochaines
années doit permettre de
résoudre cette sensibilité territoriale
c'est justement cette faculté d'écouter
les millions de VO qui chaque jour
s'exprime partout en métropole et en
outrem cette démocratie vivante et
exigeante qui tisse ce commun et je veux
rendre ici un hommage aux fonctionnaires
de l'État et des collectivités
territoriales ainsi qu'aux acteurs
locaux sans qui rien ne serait possible
à ce titre et je veux aussi remercier
tout particulièrement vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre propos liminaire les
élus locaux parce qu'ils ont pour une
très large
majorité d'entre eux une activité quasi
bénévolle et pour la totalité d'entre
eux décid de consacrer une partie
significative de leur vie à l'intérêt
général sans compter leurs heures quand
il s'agit d'écouter d'agir de retisser
ce lien en prenant des risques et
là-dessus vous l'avez rappelé je
souhaite en effet que nous puissions
faire aboutir cette réflexion déjà
commencée sur le statut de l'élu local
et en particulier les critères de
responsabilité pour pouvoir répondre à
ce qui fait aujourd'hui le quotidien de
ces élus si nous sommes ensemble
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas pour ajuster
une nouvelle fois les lois de
décentralisation aux réalités
contemporaines ou pour chercher à
expliquer aux Français en quelque sorte
que leurs vie devrait se plier à nos
organisations administratives et
institutionnelles ça fait trop longtemps
qu'on raisonne ainsi je crois d'ailleurs
que nos concitoyens n'en voit plus le
bout nous-même nous nous sommes
confrontés à l'insatisfaction en quelque
sorte de ce travail de sans sans fin en
tout cas àortter de vue et à ce
titre la
philosophie qui soutend ces conférences
nationales des territoires c'est bien
plutôt de refonder le rôle de l'État et
des collectivités territoriales dans la
vie quotidienne des Françaises et des
Français et d'adapter ce rôle aux
transitions que notre pays doit
affronter et pour pour ce faire il faut
repenser en profondeur l'interaction
entre l'État et les dites
collectivités nous connaissons
parfaitement les analyses et nous les
partageons mais ce que nous installons
aujourd'hui avec cette conférence c'est
une instance d'échange de concertation
et de décision cette conférence elle se
réunira tous les 6 mois sous la
présidence du Premier ministre elle est
composée de membres du gouvernement de
représentants des collectivités
territorial des présidents des
organismes de concertation existants et
des représentants du Parlement
elle se saisira d'un certain nombre de
thèmes transversaux ou territoriaux qui
seront traités dans la durée
elle ne doit en aucun cas conduire à
recentraliser des sujets qui relèvent du
dialogue quotidien entre les
représentants de l'État et les
collectivité dans les territoires mais
de ces négociations émergera un pacte de
confiance entre l'État et les
territoires définissant pour les C
prochaines années les engagements
respectifs que nous devons
prendre au cœur de ce
projet je place notre volonté que chaque
réforme chaque plan chaque démarche
initiée par le gouvernement pour mettre
en œuvre des politiques publiques dont
la responsabilité est partagée entre
l'État et les territoirees associe en
amont les collectivités territoriales
concernées et cette
conférence pour toutes ces raisons
monsieur le Président du Sénat ne
pouvait pour sa première réunion se
tenir ailleurs qu'ici au Sénat qui au
titre même de l'article 24 de notre
Constitution que vous avez rappelé
assure la représentation des
collectivités territorial de la
République c'était mon souhait je vous
remercie de l'avoir accepté et de nous
avoir parfaitement accueilli